[Música]
vocês vão concordar comigo é porque
alguma coisa está disponível que nós
vamos usar indiscriminadamente
não é porque eu consigo resolver com o
iraque eu tenho que resolver
principalmente se for pra cumprir uma a
vaidade dizer aí uma empresa fez uma
implementação de ar não é por aí mesmo
um recomendo algumas soluções
aí a é é a implementação probabilística
então se acontecer um acaso de uma
implementação uma solução poderá
incorrer em algum erro e esse erro por
menor que seja causa um impacto negativo
muito grande é melhor usar eu por
exemplo evitaria um marcapasso baseado
em acerto porque a conseqüência pode ser
grande é alguns casos tem que ser com a
solução determinística uma assistente
pessoal por exemplo que era uma pergunta
resposta ou outra é muito mais fácil de
consertar do que alguém que possa ficar
passo que falhou e hoje em dia a gente
tem que ter muito cuidado com essas
coisas porque há um um certo hype sobre
inteligência artificial e muitas vezes
as coisas são vendidas nem sempre podem
ser aplicadas na prática é um dos que
faz com o nosso time
lá né a um exemplo uma empresa por
exemplo pode oferecer pra gente compre
um sistema assim a maravilhoso cognitivo
de planyc emita cérebros humanos
a gente sabe que não é bem por aí pode
ser um exagero e por trás né então o
nosso papel é olhar na realidade o que
acontece é que está por trás disso
e aí a gente olhando com mais cuidado a
gente percebe que não na nossa avaliação
é um sistema é uma rede neural
artificial que consegue gradualmente
melhorar a padrões de indenizar os
traços não ser que seja isso e pode ser
até que seja uma coisa boa a gente pode
usar isso na prática
e aí quando a gente usa na prática
talvez a gente coloque dentro de um
de um serviço de um produto para o
cliente provavelmente o nosso marketing
vai vender como se fosse um sistema
cognitivo maravilhoso de pilar que
funciona com um cérebro humano né ai
tudo bem a gente tem que conviver com
isso e mais a gente sabe que isso também
é efêmera temporário
o próprio de uma caixa que foi um
pesquisador que cunhou o termo
inteligência judicial
ele fala isso que assim que a coisa
começa a funcionar para ninguém mais
percebe que é o chamo isso de a maldição
daí a e isso é verdade e lembra que o cr
é inteligência fiscal nem lembra que há
nas câmeras a gente para fazer foco a
gente precisa de ar lá no nosso
dispositivo móvel
o faz o corretor ortográfico é
inteligência artificial
apesar de às vezes parecia um rio
artificial é que é
mas melhorou muito de um ano para cá a
gente tem que dar o braço a torcer e
essa é uma característica da iaiá
diferente dos sistemas a mais
programáticos que tinham no passado né
quer coisa que chega a desenvolver e
fazer com cuidado saber todos os ao de
khamis daquilo
ai ai ela quanto mais antiga fica melhor
é trocar aí é como um todo ela vai
melhorando com o tempo até brinca um dia
alguém vai tomar um vinho e vai dizer
sim e se via como boyah é é aaa a gente
está vivendo isso e tem que ter que tem
que apreciar esses momentos porque há
espaço muito muito rápido e é justamente
porque evolui a gente tem que construir
uma estratégia não só porque evoluir mas
por tudo que eu falei
a gente conseguiu estratégia para lidar
com um texto oficial
na prática hoje nossas empresas a nossa
estratégia foi fazer tudo muito passo a
passo
a gente não queria a já de primeira já
consegui fazer ou tentar fazer a
implementação complexa
a gente quis fazer construir uma base
sólida entender cada
dodô que existe dominar a tecnologia
antes de fazer o próximo passo é meu eu
aprendi com meu avô falava se que corre
cansa
quem anda alcança a diferença é que hoje
a gente anda numa velocidade muito mais
rápida do que antigamente a primeiro
passo que a gente fez lá atrás foi
estudar o que ariar o que era
inteligência a gente olhou as definições
aí foi atrás e até pra saber qual
paralelo que tinha da parte artificial
para natural biológico ea gente
descobriu que tem uma diferença assim
tamanho à distância abissal entre os
dois
hoje pelo menos essa realidade pode ser
que chega no futuro uma coisa mais
próxima mas se a gente não consegue ver
isso tão próxima do mais a fundo
fizemos a grande descoberta de que a
artificial também colocada aqui né
o que a gente queria como como seres
humanos anti chama de especial mas o
termo inteligência tá aí só porque a
gente não tem um termo melhor pra
colocar no lugar e não está errado tá
certo a gente não tem coisa melhor pra
colocar aí as melhores definições que
fala de inteligência artificial falou
que aí é uma habilidade que máquinas tem
pra fazer tarefas como seres que são
inteligentes então definir inteligência
com inteligência não é o melhor jeito né
ah a gente criou a nossa própria
definição que mais coesa e está mais
próxima dos nossos propósitos do
contexto a gente trabalha pra justamente
conseguir a tem uma pedra de apoio e
fundamenta tudo que a gente está
aprendendo aqui pra frente ea definição
essa aqui aí a é um modelo computacional
que é capaz de emular atividade
intelectual ea palavra chave aqui é má é
ter uma referência homenagem a aal jogo
da imitação do alan turing quem sabe que
como falei antes a a máquina não falar
num
trabalho da mesma maneira que o o
biológico natural tudo bem a partir
daqui alexe tem um caminho muito sólido
a gente consiga fazer muita coisa né e
foi construindo aos pouquinhos como eu
falei até até a gente chegar na bia ea
nossa empresa bradesco inteligência
disse a nossa a a implementação de um
assistente virtual assistente digital
financeira e que responde perguntas e
ajuda as pessoas fazem transações
ela tá chegando a estar vai celebrar é
que em alguns dias a 100 milhões de
interações
isso aqui é visto no fórum do brasil no
mundo inteiro como um case de sucesso
estrondoso
a gente vai lá fora faz palestra lá fora
ea gente vê a a a platéia suspirando por
que é um número que ninguém tem nem como
conseguiu chegar até agora isso tudo com
95% de certo
isso também é a uma média a mais recente
na história recente mas também um número
que as pessoas olham assim como a gente
faz isso eu falar que um pouquinho daqui
a pouco do fator chave para que isso
aconteça tudo bem mas a bia não é uma e
apenas poderá dizer que uma soma de as é
uma soma de algoritmos que fazem outra
coisa acontecer e eu tenho 11 uma
trajetória que eu trago aqui a gente
fala que a trajetória das idéias no
campo da concepção até o momento que a
gente pode usar empresas como a gente
pode usar lá no começo as duas primeiras
etapas são hipótese pesquisa
a coisa tá muito no laboratório passa
por um momento a de apropriação que é um
momento que a gente faz com que essa
idéia seja mais a falar tável para ser
usada no mundo comercial que é um
ambiente mais hostil que o laboratório
que são escalas muito maiores e que pode
acontecer coisa que a gente não previu
anteriormente
e é esse é um momento
a sinalização que a cloud se a gente
pode ganhar empresas como a nossa pode
passar a usar aquela etec aconteceu lá
atrás
é interessante ver que cada idéia dessa
pode vingar ou não pode ser que ela
deixe de de seu último show que se é por
detrimento das outras porque há a gente
tem um limite de braço para fazer tocar
as idéias pra frente né
elas podem ser deixadas de lado e quem
sabe ser reutilizados ou descobertas
mais para frente mesmo quando a gente
está no na etapa da comercialização por
alguma um erro de implementação pode ser
que a gente deixe de usar essas idéias e
por isso que eu digo que há nem tudo o
que a gente tem tudo que foi visto antes
que foi criado antes vai chegar pra
gente nesse momento nem tudo que a gente
precisa nesse momento passou por todas
as etapas para a gente poder utilizar é
é um jogo que a gente tem que se
acomodar com que existe hoje para a
gente poder fazer aquilo que a gente
imagina que pode ser feito dentro não
importa qual é o real idéia até agora
dentro do nosso ponto de vista a gente
imagina que ele consegue classificar
qualquer coisinha em duas categorias
seja para uso pra eficiência ou seja
reduzir custos aumentar a receita será
processo ou achar alguma coisa que
humano não consegue achar sozinho essa
parceria parte da eficiência e do lado
da melhoria da experiência do
engajamento
nós temos a melhoria da interface
homem-máquina né
espero que o pessoal mesclado do homem
dono da marca é ea potencialização do
usuário eu vou falar um pouquinho mais
disse que merece ser aprofundado em
outros laid tudo bem alguém pode
perguntar mas tem um fator chave que
permeia todas essas implementações hoje
a gente vê na realidade aqui está
implementando você vê um fator chave que
que pode ser colocado atrás de tudo isso
e temos sim é imagine aqui pra fazer
isso funcionar se as e as aprendem ela
pode aprender errado a gente tem que ter
sempre algum fator que traga um método
que traga de volta o trilho é essa aí a
gente pode ter um mar de dados
nem todos esses dados são dados com
qualidade sem ter um método para
conseguir identificar qualquer dado
adequado com a informação adequada para
a gente treinar essa aí e essas duas
maneiras a gente percebe que não dá pra
fazer ainda um 100% de certeza com uma
máquina numa coisa a automatizável e aí
que tenta o fator entra o fator chave de
implementações atuais
a gente sempre precisa em algum momento
de pessoas por 3 a 1 ea equipe é o
próximo do gás nós temos pessoas muito
boas fazendo isso fazendo uma curadoria
cuidadosa da informação para que a aí a
evolua e cresça de maneira adequada eu
até falo e faço bastante e palestras que
a inteligência artificial só é possível
com sabedoria humana e é aqui que está
aquela metáfora do centauro moderno né
que é alguém que usa algum tipo de
tecnologia pra melhorar sua eficiência
para chegar em algum objetivo
a idéia é que a gente consegue se
potencializar com a tecnologia nada
disso é novo é desde quente lascou
primeira pedra para fazer uma arma a
ferramenta lá nossos antepassados a
gente estava usando a tecnologia pra nos
melhorar mas recentemente na primeira
revolução inicial
nós construímos aqui eu brinco que é o
músculo artificial para fazer o trabalho
mais braçal que a gente não conseguir
fazer nós mesmos e agora na na quarta
evolução inicial temos a haia para fazer
o quê de braçal é intelectual data desse
novo a gente usava ferramentas até
de pouco tempo pra cá até agora usamos
nossos eletrônicos para poder fazer
coisas que a gente não conseguia fazer
sem eles e daqui pra frente a gente vai
ter
aí há aqui é muita gente pergunta tu nem
mas a haia é vai substituir pessoas
porque ela vai conseguir
e não é por aí a gente sabe que há a a
tecnologia não substitui pessoas ela
pode substituir funções e aí sim eu
mesmo gostaria aqui tem de ter uma idéia
que substitui 50% das minhas funções
para ter o dobro do tempo a fazer alguma
coisa ou fazer as coisas com mais
qualidade é esse caminho que a gente
está a gente está defendendo é é a idéia
da iaiá humanista
hoje nós temos em extremos opostos de um
do espectro duas linhas que também são
muito sedutores e perigosas né
de um lado a gente tem um falando aí a a
os os apocalípticos analistas radicais
aqui que acho que é uma super
inteligência que vai tomar nossos
empregos que vai esgotar os recursos e
vai acabar com a raça humana
do outro lado temos os outros citados
solucione estas que acho que aí vai
resolver toda e qualquer problema
inclusive aqueles que a gente está
criando hoje porque no futuro e vai
transformar o nosso habitat num único
ano no paraíso pra gente viver aqui na
nossa perspectiva humilde que quem está
vendo tudo isso acontecer e acha que
nenhum e outros se sustenta né há um
caminho no meio pra gente fazer isso
ian e é o caminho que a gente tenta
colocar em prática aqui hoje é de um
lado a gente tem que ter o os limites de
controle para saber até onde que a coisa
não vai degringolar
e aqui nos limites de possibilidades
para saber até onde a gente consegue
realmente pra fazer a funcionar pra
gente
foi nessa linha eu trago para vocês uma
lista de preocupações anseios que a
gente necessidade que a gente traz pra
tentar melhorar a tecnologia para fazer
a coisa funcionar o nosso do
a gente imagina que deveria funcionar no
futuro a lado da evolução das
importações a explicar habilidade que é
o fato de a gente ter a maior
visibilidade de quais são os originais e
como eles são usados para manter coisa
de efeito caixa preta à privacidade e
segurança pra mim correr no mesmo erro
que a gente correu com a internet porque
sim essa plataforma pode ser distribuído
global como a internet então a gente tem
que evitar isso e por fim a ausência de
vieses porque viés é tanto o banco
enquanto vírus dahia o banco porque pode
ser um defeito que pode beber em
viabilizar até desmoralizar e a um vírus
porque se está inserido em uma
plataforma que é usada por várias
empresas está se propagando e do lado da
sustentabilidade da tecnologia ética
ética não consigo deixar de falar ética
isso aqui dá uma palestras por si só
só pra falar desse ponto o filho quer
deixar para vocês a mensagem essa
mensagem aqui
não que a inteligência artificial é
contra as pessoas muito pelo contrário o
que a gente defende justamente que as
pessoas podem ser potencializadas pela
inteligência artificial
cada um cada um de nós que algumas
pessoas pode se valer dela pra melhorar
a como o corpo humano
a gente só tem que entender quais são os
limites escolher quais são os seus
limites
os governos têm que se aprofundar
entender aonde até onde ele pode dar aí
há pra melhorar a vida dos cidadãos têm
que talvez a gente até pensar em criar
regulamentações que além de garantir os
direitos do cidadão e linense eo tas um
uso melhor da ciência e tecnologias como
essa aqui há muito o que fazer
há muito que se evoluir tanto
tecnicamente quanto sou sócio
culturalmente na inteligência especial
é verdade que hoje a iata à nossa volta
e até aqui para ficar
a gente tem a
no nosso dia a dia mesmo que a gente não
perceba e aí de uma kate continua certo
a gente não está percebendo mas no fim
das contas pode ser que a gente tenha se
contentar em desenvolver uma coisa que
ninguém percebe mais que é inteligência
judicial mas o fim do dia mas a gente
ficar com melhores humanos
muito obrigado